[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti io sono un oncologo
il medico dei tumori ma sapete che cos'è
un tumore un tumore è un insieme di
cellule e i nostri tessuti sono formati
normalmente da cellule che si dividono
per un delicato equilibrio però per
tante cellule che si formano altrettante
ne muoiono quindi il numero finale
rimane lo stesso nei tumori questo
meccanismo fine di regolazione viene a
perdersi e tumore i tumori hanno queste
cellule che crescono in maniera
incontrollata occupando tutto lo spazio
a loro disposizione da più di 60 anni
utilizziamo la chemioterapia e voglio
dirlo con grande chiarezza la
chemioterapia per i tumori funziona
il problema è che ho un po come i
missili cruise di donald trump a
specifica ovvero uccide tutte le cellule
che proliferano quelle cattive a quelle
tumorali ma anche quelle buone come per
esempio quelle dei bulbi ca piliferi o
del sangue negli ultimi anni abbiamo
fatto importanti passi avanti e siamo
passati dalla chemioterapia dei
trattamenti molto più specifici per
esempio la target therapy terapia a
bersaglio molecolare
sono i cosiddetti farmaci intelligenti
ovvero quelli in grado di capire chi sia
la cellula da colpire ovvero quella che
ha il recettore di membrana una sorta di
etichetta che ci consente appunto di
riconoscerla
il passo successivo ed è quello di cui
vorrei parlarvi oggi
l'immunoterapia estremamente
affascinante ovvero la capacità del
nostro stesso sistema immunitario di
eliminare le cellule riconosciute come
diverse in futuro
la farmacogenomica ovvero identificare
il trattamento più attivo e meno tossico
per ciascuno di noi
il cambiamento di prospettiva se
vogliamo è rivoluzionario infatti siamo
passati dalla cellula o della cellula
con il suo recettore di membrana a
quello che sta attorno
ovvero il cibo macro environment o
microambiente tumorale sono cellule come
linfociti cellule dendritiche e
macrofagi ma facciamo un passo indietro
io mi occupo specificamente di sarcoma
sono tumori rari estremamente aggressivi
esordiscono in genere fra i 14 ei 16
anni e colpiscono principalmente l'osso
per poi estendersi ai tessuti
circostanti il trattamento fondamentale
è rappresentato dalla chirurgia come per
molti tumori solidi ma da sola non basta
la probabilità di cura con la sola
chirurgia del solo 10 per cento perché 9
su 10 pazienti ricadono come tassani psi
polmonari solo dopo pochi mesi dopo
l'intervento e questo grafico mostra gli
importanti cambiamenti e miglioramenti
che abbiamo a cui abbiamo assistito dal
1960 al 2010 con un aumento della
sopravvivenza dal 10 al 65 per cento e
questo vedete la riga blu in alto grazie
all'introduzione della chemioterapia per
di più collocando la chemioterapia
prima dell'intervento chirurgico la
necessità di ricorrere all'amputazione è
scesa dal 90 a meno del 5 per cento
ma c'è un problema il problema di questa
curva sta sulla sinistra ovvero è una
riga piatta non ci sono stati più
ulteriori progressi negli ultimi anni
il motivo è semplice nessun nuovo
farmaco approvato per lost sarcoma
per più di 20 anni nonostante veramente
molteplici siano gli studi e le ricerche
finalmente nel 2009 succede qualcosa
le ma l'agenzia europea per il farmaco
approva il mi fa mortine un
immunostimolante per questo tumore
l'idea di utilizzare il nostro stesso
sistema immunitario contro i tumori
ovvero vaccinarsi contro una cellula
tumorale come facciamo per i virus ha da
sempre affascinato i medici e
ricercatori ed è possibile perché sulle
cellule tumorali ci sono i cosiddetti
antigeni nelle proteine di membrana che
ne consentono il riconoscimento
il problema è l'efficienza
dell'eliminazione ovvero questo sistema
riconosce molto bene ma poi non elimina
il tumore anche sono i responsabili per
i suoi saperi sono principalmente i
linfociti queste cellule dell'immunità
che al microscopio ottico come vedete
sono tutte molto semplici e omogenee in
realtà fanno parte di un sistema
estremamente complesso che troviamo nel
sangue negli organi linfoidi primari e
secondari come per esempio milza e
linfonodi
infine anche dentro i nostri stessi
tumori e proprio dentro questi tumori
che è iniziata la ricerca del mio
laboratorio
abbiamo infatti analizzato le biopsie
veri tessuti all'inizio di qualsiasi
trattamento di più di 100 pazienti tutti
avevano meno di 40 anni
tutti avevano una diagnosi di
osteosarcoma localizzato all'esordio
tutti erano stati trattati con lo stesso
protocollo di chemioterapia e dalla
stessa equipe chirurgica quindi in
teoria avrebbero dovuto avere chance di
guarigione molto simili
quello che abbiamo visto è profondamente
diverso infatti quando in questi tessuti
non erano presenti i linfociti ovvero
questi soldati dell'immunità la
probabilità di guarigione era inferiore
al 150 per cento
quando invece erano presenti sin
dall'inizio la probabilità saliva a più
dell'ottanta per cento
probabilmente sarebbe molto importante
differenziare i trattamenti sin
dall'inizio e utilizzare gli
immunoterapici assieme alla
chemioterapia nel sottogruppo appunto
senza linfociti la buona notizia è che
questi farmaci sono adesso disponibili
si chiamano inibitori dei check point
non so se ne abbiate sentito parlare ma
non mi stupirebbe perché negli ultimi
tre anni praticamente in diversi tumori
vedete melanoma ma anche tumore del rene
tumori veramente aggressivi come tumori
il tumore del polmone sono stati
approvati cosa vuol dire approvati vuol
dire che io posso prescriverli ma che
prima si è dimostrato un importante
aumento di sopravvivenza nel gruppo in
cui erano utilizzati che per il polmone
arriva persino a quattro volte in più
e questi farmaci agiscono e legandosi
alla membrana delle cellule
dell'immunità appunto stimolando il
stimolandole nei sarcomi siamo un po
indietro
vi presento un singolo caso presentato
l'anno scorso da un gruppo collaborativo
americano vedete è una metastasi
polmonari nel cerchio in rosso trattata
con inibitori di pd e uno dopo due mesi
assistiamo a un importante riduzione di
questa metastasi e 8 mesi abbiamo una
pressoché scomparsa di tutte le
metastasi polmonari in italia ci stiamo
muovendo su due fronti
la ricerca preclinica nel mio
laboratorio abbiamo messo a punto un
modello con cellule dendritiche e due
linee cellulare di sarcoma dell'oste dei
sarcomi delle parti molli studiare
solamente immunoterapici ma la miglior
combinazione di i monotematici e
inibitori per esempio dell'angiogenesi
dal sul versante clinico da quest'anno i
pazienti con sarcoma potranno avere
accesso a due diversi trial clinici
sperimentali a bologna 1 in
collaborazione con l'università di oslo
e il secondo in collaborazione con il
gruppo spagnolo per i sarcomi il futuro
sarà un ulteriore cambiamento di
prospettiva dalla cellula abbiamo
guardato intorno alla cellula il passo
avanti sarà guardare al contenitore
stesso del tumore
ovvero l'ospite il paziente stesso
infatti grandi grande impegno in questa
nuova diciamo disciplina si chiama
farmacogenomica in parole semplici a
utilizzare le informazioni genetiche non
solo di uno specifico tumore ma anche
del suo ospite il paziente per predire
se un trattamento sarà attivo oppure
tossico per un particolare individuo
quella che chiamiamo medicina
personalizzata
quello che voglio dirvi adesso però
ancora più importante tutte le ricerche
richiedono veramente anni e quindi credo
che sia utile che da oggi tutti quanti
facciamo qualcosa per migliorare la
probabilità di avere un tumore
ovvero seguire un adeguato stile di vita
ed è semplice basta seguire delle regole
per esempio la regola 05 30 ovvero 0
sigarette al giorno cinque volte volte
pasti a base di frutta o verdura e 30
minuti di attività fisica
al giorno
prima di salutarvi e volevo che
ascoltassimo insieme questa canzone
[Musica]
la riconoscete si chiama children ed è
una delle opere più importanti di uno
dei più grandi dj di ibiza e del mondo
robert miles robert miles è morto questa
settimana per un tumore dopo solo nove
mesi
dedico quindi le mie ricerche a tutte le
persone che come lui hanno combattono
contro dei tumori che ancora non
conosciamo abbastanza
grazie
[Applauso]